Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. When I was growing up in 1970s Britain, one of my favourite possessions was my two-part set of the Lady Bird, Kings and Queens of England, the narrative structure on which my entire knowledge of history was built. And that's true, isn't it, Tom, of lots of people. So kings and queens are the sort of, they're still the kind of idiom. Yeah, they're the scaffolding, aren't they? Yeah,
they are. But certainly you kind of work out English and then British history. Absolutely. The Elizabethan age, the Georgians, the Victorians, you know, the Plantagenets, they are the sort of foundational, they're the foundation stones, aren't they? Absolutely. Which is why i think that um this world cup that we've been doing so we should explain people who haven't caught up with all the fun and excitement uh we've been running a world cup of uh kings and queens of england uh so from athelstan all the way through to elizabeth ii um we uh in the in uh in our very first episode we looked at the the unexpected champion it was actually athelstan the yes the first king who can probably i think be called the king
of of england so a lot of people commented tom that uh were we basically saying that it had all been downhill uh since then i think i mean i think that's a reasonable conclusion to draw isn't it yeah you should uh you should write that article for unheard there's a reasonable conclusion to draw, isn't it? Yeah. You should write that article for Unheard. They get a bit of extra promotion. Yes. I hope they give us a bonus for that. Yes, I should. Well, I haven't been asked, actually.
That's shocking. I can't believe that. Well, no, actually, we were, weren't we? They did ask us. They asked us to write about Athelstan and Elizabeth I, and we couldn't because we were too busy. And we were too busy or too lazy depending on I think too
That's shocking. I can't believe that. Well, no, actually, we were, weren't they? They did ask us. They asked us to write about Athelstan and Elizabeth I, and we couldn't because we were too busy. And we were too busy or too lazy depending on I think too
but we were genuinely too busy I think we were genuinely too busy anyway so that was that was the first episode we did and then we did the one that went out yesterday was on the the losing contestants
in the Super 16s round yeah so now we come to the quarterfinals and the semifinals and the quarterfinals were Henry V against Elizabeth II, Henry VIII against William I, the conqueror,
Charles II against Elizabeth I, and Edward III against Athelstan. Some big games there. Massive games. Well, I mean, you'd expect that, wouldn't you, in the quarterfinals of a major global tournament? You would. So the first match,
Henry V against Elizabeth II. global tournament you would um so the first match um henry v against elizabeth ii henry v a very proactive dashing charismatic king yeah smites the french against elizabeth ii who's who's basically in this contest because essentially she's done nothing that's very harsh she's done nothing but in a very politically savvy way yes she, she's done nothing very well. I mean, we'll come on to Elizabeth II and the way that 20th century, 21st century monarchy differs very radically, obviously, from, say, medieval exemplars. But Dominic, Henry V is absolutely the model
of a warrior king. The issue is how much he's been created by shakespeare isn't it so most people's image of henry v comes from well it comes from sort of children's book illustrations with his bowl haircut yeah his bowl haircut and he's waving a sword and he's got always always the leopards the lions of england and the fleur-de-lis yeah he's sort of scaling the walls at harfleur he's in the mud with all his bowmen at Agincourt. He's receiving a gift of tennis balls from the French. And does he throw them back?
Or he says, because they say to him, stay in England and play tennis, you wet weed. And he says that I will serve such a game as has never been seen in France before. And so he does, to be fair to him. Now, there are... One issue with Henry V is the trajectory of the story, which is irresistible, which is the sort of... In the popular imagination, he goes from this sort of laddish rogue
hanging around with Falstaff, or indeed Sir John Oldcastle, who's the character that Falstaff is based on, to this sort of stern, rigorous, very pious, martial warlord. Yes. And that's kind of an invention, isn't it? It's apparently a complete invention. So he was never the sort of Royster Doyster
who was falling out of taverns and consulting the ladies. Buffeting the ears of the Lord Chief Justice. Yeah, that didn't happen, did it? No, it didn't. And obviously Falstaff didn't exist. So that no it didn't and and obviously full staff didn't exist so that whole i know the not old man banishing he's become a responsible leader banishing the follies of his youth all of this is a myth and i think as you said i mean it absolutely points to the way in which shakespeare has shaped and so you talked about um the the
ladybird books and i agree that those kind of children's books that go through the kings and queens of England are massive, massive influences. But I think also that on the 15th century in particular, Shakespeare is an absolutely outsized influence on the way that people understand the kings of that period. So Henry V and Richard III, they're the kind of polar opposites, aren't they? Yeah. So Richard III is the villain. Henry V is the absolute hero. But having said that, I mean, Henry V was clearly a very, very, if you're saying martial success and ability to defeat the French is the measure of effective kingship, he was a very, very effective king. Although you could argue he wastes a lot of resources in a war that ultimately england loses well you know that i think that so it avails us nothing in the long run i mean he wasn't to know that though was he i mean he wasn't
to know that in the 1410s because he dies young at the age of 35 and 1422 of a combination of dysentery and heat stroke, having apparently subdued the French and secured his own claim to the French throne. When the French king dies, Henry will succeed him and unite France and England. But then he dies and it's all for nothing. But I suppose he wasn't to know that. I mean, he could have lived to the age of 55 and maybe who knows, you know, a Franco-Anglo-French union of crowns. Or do you think that's just utterly laughable and implausible? I don't think that would ever have happened. I mean, I just don't think the French would have accepted it.
And I think that the resources of France were so vastly greater than those of England. I mean, it was like those images you occasionally get from Australia or something, of a snake trying to swallow an improbable kangaroo or something. And for a while it looks good, but then the kangaroo bursts out. It does happen, though. Some listeners will remember, for example, our Alexander the Great podcast, in which a small group of adventurers... Yeah, but that didn't work, did it?
The whole thing fell to pieces and disintegrated. Well, but it changed the course of history. I mean, who's to say that France would have emerged as it did in the 16th and 17th centuries as such a superpower if it had been ruled by the English for longer? Well, there were two options. Either the French, you know, in the reign of Henry VI,
you know, if he succeeds when he's 40 or something, he'd still have been useless. They would have thrown English rule off. Yeah. Or you would have had a kind of thrown english rule off yeah or uh you would have had a kind of anglo-french condominium but because france was so much richer so much more sophisticated so much classier um england would have ended up kind of supernumerary i think oh dear tom well that's terrible so essentially i i think there was no way that it that it would
have been good uh you're down on Henry V generally, aren't you? I do think he's the most overrated figure in English history. Why? Well, because I think that he squandered money. I think it was essentially a vainglorious episode. Shakespeare in his play, Henry IV's dying advice to Henry V, busy giddy minds with foreign troubles. That's basically what he's doing.
Because the Lancastrian house, Henry IV, Henry of Lancaster, has deposed his cousin, Richard II, the son of the Black Prince, the grandson of Edward III. And that's a terrible thing to do. You can't go around deposing kings, because these are anointed, anointed of God. So Henry IV labours under a kind of nagging anxiety that he has offended against God. Yeah. And I think Henry V is heir to that as well. So when Henry V becomes, when Henry becomes king, he brings Richard II's body to Westminster Abbey
and buries it with all due splendour. And again, Shakespeare on the eve of Agincourt has him kind of say, think not upon the fault my father made in compassing the ground, words to that effect. So there's this sense that even Henry has that God is going to punish the House of Lancaster at some point. And basically, it's a squalid campaign that goes vastly that goes vastly better than than anyone could have anticipated i mean he's running enormous risk he very nearly gets captured
that would then have bankrupted england because they would have had to pay his ransom yeah i mean it was absolutely irresponsible risk but he won but he won he does win but in the long run england doesn't and okay the blowback from their defeat in France is a crucial part. And, of course, the blowback of the original Lancastrian usurpation results in the Wars of the Roses. So I think that Henry V is essentially putting a rather flamboyant sticking plaster on some rather deep wounds there. Golly, that's harsh. However, having said that, I think he's, I mean, let's play devil's harsh. However, however, having said that, having said that, I think he's, I mean, let's pay devil's advocate.
He's very dashing. So, yes. So, Tom, just one quick question before we move on. I remember reading a book by the historian Ian Mortimer talking about Henry V and his road to Agincourt. And he painted Henry V as an ultra-pious, almost a kind of a religious, you know, sort of a very kind of ascetic figure very
almost a religious kind of fundamentalist or something is that a bit overdone do you think or is that is that no i think i think he was very i mean i think i think he was absolutely and this is an awful story of him um that you know it's the age of the lolards yes um kind of so that's a protestant yeah and and one of them is is being burnt and he cries out to god and henry v hears him crying out to god so orders the fire the flames to be put out and asks if he's repented and the lolard says no so henry v orders the fires to be lit again wow re-burning. Yeah. Yes. So robust attitude. However, I mean, to play devil's advocate, clearly he is a magnificent warrior. And one of the reasons why we know that he's not hanging out with Falstaff is that, I mean, basically he's been fighting since a very, very young age.
He fought at the Battle of Shrewsbury, didn't he? Well, he's born in Monmouth, so he's on the Anglo-Welsh border. Yes, he fights at the Battle of Shrewsbury against Owen Glendower, who is a kind of, I suppose, a kind of proto-Welsh national leader, and against the Percys, who are the overmighty subjects from the north. And then, of course, he does, you know, I mean, there's no getting away from that. He's very effective at fighting the French, which is, you've got to give him some credit for that I suppose
he's also the first he's the first king to use English in his private correspondence since oh that's nice since 1066 that's a nice detail
so we'll give him that yeah and he's been the hero of some fabulous films I mean I think the Olivier film is brilliant it still holds up
the Branagh film is yeah very good I'll tell you a terrible film uh it's the timothy chalamet one have you seen that no i haven't came out that got quite laudatory reviews as i know it was awful uh so it got re they rewrote shakespeare and they kind of basically and um john falstaff in that one doesn't die and he accompanies hen V to France. And at some point, Henry, Timothy Chalamet,
turns to John Falstaff and says, John, John Falstaff says, yes. And Henry V says, John, I just want to thank you for being you. Oh,
you're kidding. He's serious. Yeah. That's what they got rid of Shakespeare's. Immortal first. Oh, my word. I don't want to sound old-fashioned, but that's not an advance, is it? That's definitely not an advance.
All right, so that's Henry V. Let us move on to another larger-than-life character. The larger-than-life character in all English history. Probably the monarch. I mean, I think we said this the other day on yesterday's podcast, that this is the monarch who is best known around the world, and that is, of course, Henry VIII. Six wives, gargantuan appetite, break with Rome, capricious, charismatic, magnetic personality,
a great lover of tennis, of music, of dressing up in hoods, a great Bullingdon man. So hopefully you'll be doing your impersonation. So yeah, a tremendous... And the hero of a top book. A top children's book. A top children's book.
Well, you say the hero. You see, Henry VIII, I think in a funny way, I think he's a little bit underestimated. Because I think the one thing people never appreciate with Henry VIII, who is, of course, the king at the beginning of the first part of the 16th century, the great Reformation king, is how insecure his position is when he takes over. Because you're talking about being the son of a usurper.
I mean, he too is the son of a usurper in Henry VII, who's won the crown on the battlefield, and Henry VIII and his stuff with his six wives and all the sort of beheadings and whatnot. That only makes sense if you understand it against the background of the Wars of the Roses and the insecurity of his position. Family tree shenanigans is, I think, the phrase he used yesterday. Family tree shenanigans.
Yeah, so I think Henry VIII, I think he gets a bit of a bad press i mean obviously he was terribly fat he was capricious all these things but he becomes fat doesn't he but yeah but all king i mean i was only reading that we will be discussing edward the third later on he becomes very fat and old and capricious so with henryIII, I think what people underestimate is the extent to which people at the time thought he was the model of a king. Don't you? Or am I being too kind? I think that the reason for Henry VIII's celebrity is clearly partly his wives. We've done a whole episode on them. And it's this kind of idea of him as a blue beard, a wife murderer.
And that gives him the quality of an ogre. I mean, literally an ogre. And we don't actually have many ogre-ish kings. I mean, we've had frightening kings. So Edward I is clearly a frightening king. Richard I is a frightening king. Cromwell in his own way is a kind of a frightening, intimidating figure. But Henry VIII is, I mean, he's a proper tyrant, but he's a glamorous tyrant.
And I think it's that blend of glamour and tyranny. I mean, he's the one that's closest to a Nero or a kind of, you know, that model of a Roman emperor. It's the charisma, isn't it? It's the charm and the charisma. It's the charisma and the bloodiness that combines. And I think that that, so Froissart, who we'll probably come on to when we talk about Edward III, the great French historian of the 14th century, says of the English that basically they're very, very disrespectful towards their kings and they
expect their kings to do what they want them to do. And that kings exist on sufferance in England, you know, which is a striking thing for him to say, you know, three years, three centuries before execution of Charles I. Henry VIII, you know, you've said how precarious his position is when he begins, but he really rests it round. And what he does to, you know, to the Roman church, what he does to the aristocracy, what he does to anybody who dares to stand up to him. I mean, he is a tyrannical figure. But the contrast to that is obviously the previous century. So the Wars of the Roses and Henry VI.
So, yeah, for a 16th century monarch, you look back at the recent at the recent past you say well we had this dreadful drip in henry the sixth he was very kind um who who thought about god who was very nice to small children and animals and he was an absolute dead loss the barons were completely out of control there was anarchy and civil war and all this sort of stuff and you have to be formidable and also henry's living in an age henry the eighth is living in an age of as we talked about before of incredibly formidable kings so francis of um france king francois or charles v the emperor the holy roman emperor the king of spain i mean they are titanic figures but it's a tribute to henry isn't it that he can even be measured in the same mentioned in the same breath i mean england is is such a kind of second division power yeah compared to france or the empire that the very idea of comparing them is
is kind of comical so it's that also is a tribute to his charisma i think and he's also consequential in a way that is not true of all the monarchs on this list i mean you mentioned elizabeth we'll come to elizabeth ii let's be frank even the greatest admirer of the Queen could not possibly claim that she is a really consequential monarch. She's a uniting figure and she's consensual and all that stuff, but she hasn't changed anything. Henry VIII changes the entire destiny of the country because, of course, given that France had been a hotbed of Protestantism, but ends up as a Catholic country, ends up as the exemplar of sort of Catholic absolutism. It's not inevitable that England will be Protestant.
I mean, it could easily have remained loyal to the Roman Church. No, no. And England was famously devoted to the Church of Rome, to of the key symbolic moments in Henry's reign is when he orders the desecration of the Shrine of Thomas Beckett, who we talked about in reference to Henry II. Played by some absolutely top-class actors. Yes, some top actors who missed their vocation. I mean, Beckett posthumously is the victor over Henry II. But Henry VIII, you know, he smashes up Thomas Beckett's tomb, has his relics, you know, burnt and chucked into the river. I mean, Henry triumphs over Beckett.
I met an American Jesuit who was over in England, I think for a year or something. And he was telling me that he'd been to Windsor and he'd been to the chapel where Henry VIII is buried um and there was obviously kind of ropes around the the tomb and he said that when no one was looking he jumped over the ropes and danced on Henry VIII's tomb that's a bit much so so um there are still deeply felt wounds um yeah of course, another paradox of Henry's role is that in the long run, his reign proves to be a turning point in the relationship of the monarchy to parliament.
Yeah. Or it's an old fashioned view. I think, well, that's controversial among historians. I know it's controversial, but I mean, I think it's indisputable that Henry's reign does not damage the reputation and the potency of Parliament.
Yeah, that's true. I mean, let's phrase it like that. And also, Henry, he's an ambiguous figure because he is himself, deep down, theologically still quite Catholic, isn't he? So when we were doing the World Cup on Twitter, I posted a facetious tweet that Henry had invented tennis, music, and Protestantism. And lots of people replied saying, he wasn't even a real Protestant. He didn't actually invent music either. Well, I mean, Luther thought he was – I mean, obviously,
he had had a bust up with Luther because he'd written a defense of the papacy, of the Church of Rome, which is why Defender of the Faith remains the title of the British monarch to this day. But even once he'd broken with Rome, I mean, Luther thought that he was mad, that Henry had basically proclaimed himself God.
Yeah. Well, he proclaims himself God's vicegerent in his own kingdom, doesn't he? And then gets Cromwell to smash up the monasteries for him because he wants the money. So the fascination of Henry's reign is that, to me, the fascination is that perfect combination of kind of opportunism, of avarice, of political calculation in the context of genuine evangelical fervor. And it's the interaction of those things
that makes it such a fascinating story. And then you put the wives on top of that and the court machinations and stuff. And it becomes this, you can understand why Hilary Mantel, why Shakespeare, why legions of kind of novelists have found all this so fascinating.
Because I think more than any other monarchical story in our history, it has a cocktail of every possible ingredient. It's interesting that some of our greatest writers have detested him. So Charles Dickens in his children's history, the plain truth is that he was a most intolerable ruffian, a disgrace to human nature and a blot of blood and grease upon the history of England.
And Jane Austen, and Jane Austen, Henry VIII, his only merit was his not being quite so bad as his daughter, Elizabeth. Oh, golly, that's harsh. Tracy Borman wouldn't like that. Tracy Borman would be absolutely outraged. But you see, Hilary Mantel, one of the things I think that was really good about Hilary Mantel's
Warfall trilogy, which I do think actually, like a lot of people, went on a bit too uh is that it it captures the magnetism of henry he is an attractive person to be around particularly at first he's an exciting person and i think that's absolutely how he must have seemed he was a giant wasn't he and he's he's brilliant at all these things he's he's brilliant at sport he is he speaks five languages he's fascinated by scientific instruments yeah he but i mean he that obviously he's a renaissance prince yeah he's an absolute renaissance prince but um but isn't it a bit like victoria that we were talking yesterday about how she goes from jemma coleman to yes this kind of judy dench
judy with no intervening period yes and it's the judy dench period that dominates yeah and with henry i suppose because of holbein so again dickens is brilliant on this and he says that he's talking about when he was 18 he said people said he was handsome then but i don't believe it he was a big burly noisy small-eyed large-faced double-chinned swinish looking fellow in later life as we know from the likenesses of him painted by the famous hans holbein and it is not easy to believe that so bad a character can ever have been veiled under a prepossessing appearance so he went from maybe the way to think of him as having gone from kind of jude law to jude law to johnny vegas yes
but it's johnny vegas it's that incarnation that we imagine, isn't it? It is. I mean, it's the kind of fat. And Dominic, did... Was there perhaps a treatment that his physicians gave him that has been mentioned in a top children's book? A top podcast, I think we talked about. Didn't we talk about it in the podcast?
Yeah, we did. But I wondered whether perhaps you'd like to well listeners some listeners may remember that Henry's doctors had to insert a silver tube into his bottom and squirt him
with a mixture of herbs and milk and honey from a pig's bladder yes a treatment that I've never tried but some some listeners we could do it live
on the podcast we could when we do our top 10 enemas that we can culminate with a live... A live squirting from our pig's bladder. Maybe we'll invite the worst guest we've had. We'll choose our worst guest and subject them to this treatment.
That's a lovely image. Right, let's move on. Tom is laughing too much to talk, so I will take command of the podcast. We should take a break and we'll come back with Charles II after the break. Again, we're in a Rachel Morley situation because we've only done two and we've got to do four more. That's because we got sidelined by ludicrous… Top ten enemas.
Yeah, right. Okay, well, we won't do that in the second half. We'll be much more responsible. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. Bye-bye. to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
Now, while you were listening to the ads, Tom was actually trying out that enema treatment and he's back now. He looks refreshed, cleansed. Yes, purged, I think is the word. He's purged, exactly. So, Tom, a great character. The third quarterfinal, Charles II against Elizabeth I. Elizabeth I absolutely murdered Charles II.
She did. Elizabeth I did to Charles II what Cromwell would have liked to do. Yeah. Dispatched him. So, Charles II was a seed, mainly thanks to your advocacy and Tracy Borman. I would not have had him as a seed. I would have had Cromwell as a seed, I think. But he's a kind of an attractive figure.
He's a great character. He's a character, isn't he? So he's the son of Charles I. Civil War, at the end of Civil War, he goes into exile. He comes back, to um launch an invasion of england from scotland uh gets defeated at the battle of worcester by cromwell has to rush around hiding in oak trees and things um sails away from shoreham uh spends the rest of the of cromwell's protectorate in uh in the netherlands and then in 1660 is restored. Yeah, and issues the Declaration of Breda,
so he comes back promising kind of relative... Limited, tender consciences. Yeah, relative tolerance and sort of... Although it is relative, isn't it? Because 1662, the Act of Uniformity is a kind of... Yeah, exactly. There is the Clarendon Code, which is seen as a sort of an attempt to institute Anglicanism
and to be a bit more intolerant to people who are outside the society. To dissenters, exactly. And then he's involved in a series of, I mean, a series of very high profile events. Obviously, there's the Great Fire of London. There's a plague. traditionally have seen as the birth of politics with the exclusion crisis when uh parliament tries to get rid of his to exclude his brother james duke of york from the succession because he's catholic and you get the first sort of the first vestiges of kind of of factional of factions coalescing into wigs and tories um but it's also char is and also I should mention
because our Dutch followers are always going on about this but apparently there was some war between England and the Dutch Republic that the Dutch won
but that sounds very improbable I think we should give that no thought at all listen we'll just draw a veil over that and not even mention it but he
but you've been to the Writes Museum I have yeah I've seen all those paintings of naval victories that I've never heard of. I know, you go in, it's just full of paintings of the Dutch beating the English. Yeah. It's absolutely shocking.
It should be allowed, isn't it? They're just minor skirmishes, aren't they, in English waters, I think. Ludicrously overinflated. So we don't know what the Dutch are going on about. Anyway, so let's focus on more important things because, of course, the most famous thing about Charles II is that he had lots of mistresses he did nell gwynn um he had who was as i recall from 1066 and all that was she selling oranges she was and she was one of the top 10 mistresses was she that you missed because you were malingering yeah yeah there's
barbara villius lady cast. Yeah, she's great. And Peep sees her underwear. He does. He's very excited by it, isn't he? Yes, he is. There's Louise de Kerouac. Yeah, the Duchess of Portsmouth. And there's Francis Stewart, who resists his importunities.
barbara villius lady cast. Yeah, she's great. And Peep sees her underwear. He does. He's very excited by it, isn't it? Yes, he is. There's Louise de Kerouac. Yeah, the Duchess of Portsmouth. And there's Francis Stewart, who resists his importunities.
And she then becomes the model for Britannia on the coinage. That I didn't know. That's a good fact. He's also a great scientist. So he's very interested in science. He's instrumental, instrumental obviously in the royal society and in the royal observatory in 1616 in january 16th there's a great entry in peeps's diary tom uh peeps meets uh charles the second in the park on going for a walk with his brother james and they go afterwards to the king's little elaboratory so a place where you elaborate yes so that's where
that's where the laboratory comes from which i didn't know so you go and elaborate there did you know that no that's the great thing about this podcast i'm learning new things we're learning all the time so peep said it was a pretty place and he there saw a great i saw a great many chemical glasses and things but understood none of them which is exactly how i felt as a teenager yeah Yes, science lessons. Yes. And Prince Rupert was a keen chemist as well. Very well, absolutely.
这就是实验室的由来，我以前都不知道，所以你去那边详细了解了，你知道吗？不，这就是这个播客最棒的地方，我在学习新东西，我们一直在学习。所以皮普说那是个很漂亮的地方，他在那里看到了很多很多的化学玻璃器皿之类的东西，但完全看不懂，这跟我青少年时的感觉一模一样，对，没错，科学课。是的，鲁珀特王子也是个狂热的化学家。非常厉害，绝对是的。
The Stuarts, they're great scientists. Great scientists, but also, and we should mention this, also a great enthusiast for the slave trade. Yes. So Rupert was definitely involved in it. Was Charles II involved in the slave trade? I think he was. I think he was an investor in... An investor, but let's face. Was Charles II involved in the slave trade? I think he was. I think he was an investor in... An investor.
斯图亚特家族，他们都是伟大的科学家。伟大的科学家，但同时——我们应该提到这一点——也是奴隶贸易的狂热支持者。是的。所以鲁珀特绝对参与其中。查理二世参与奴隶贸易了吗？我想他参与了。我想他是……一个投资者，但说实话，查理二世参与奴隶贸易了吗？我想他参与了。我想他是……一个投资者。
But let's face it, if you're in the Stuart Court in the mid-17th century, everyone's an investor, right? Okay. But I think just mention that because that was something that I saw kind of bubbling up. Did you? I didn't see that. I don't follow that part of Twitter. It may amaze you to... Well, I was just scanning through seeing what people were saying about all the various kings.
但说实话，如果你身处17世纪中叶的斯图亚特宫廷，每个人都是投资者，对吧？好吧。不过我觉得还是提一下比较好，因为我看到这种说法正在某种程度上酝酿。是吗？我没看到。我不关注推特的那一部分。你可能会惊讶于……好吧，我只是随便浏览了一下，看看大家对各个国王都有什么评价。
So looking at the negatives as well as the positives and that's I guess it's kind of up there with wiping out Irish towns expelling the Jews and investment in the slave trade are still black marks
所以既要看到消极面，也要看到积极面，我想这就像血洗爱尔兰城镇、驱逐犹太人以及投资奴隶贸易一样，仍然是抹不掉的污点。
the big thing at the time of course so he signs a secret treaty with Louis XIV, in which Louis XIV basically says he will pay him £230,000 if Charles, A, joins that war with the Dutch, which is a shambles, which you mentioned earlier. Which we're crossing a veil over. Secretly, if he converts to Catholicism and will come out as a Catholic and lead England towards Catholicism,
当然，当时最重大的事情是，他与路易十四秘密签署了一项条约，路易十四基本上表示，如果查理满足以下条件，将支付他23万英镑：A，加入那场一团糟的对荷战争，也就是你刚才提到的那场。我们对此暂且不表。秘密地，如果他改信天主教，公开成为天主教徒，并引导英格兰走向天主教，
something that Charles actually has no intention of doing. But he does on his deathbed, doesn't he? Supposedly he does on his deathbed, exactly. So clearly Charles had, shall we say, papal sympathies, and he takes this money from the French. And this has sometimes been held against him by kind of Protestant Whiggish historians, but who also see him as conniving and weasel-like
而查理实际上根本无意这样做。但他临终前确实这么做了，对吧？据说他临终前确实这么做了，没错。所以很显然，查理有着（我们可以这么说）亲天主教的倾向，并且他拿了法国人的钱。新教辉格党历史学家有时会以此指责他，但他们同时也认为他狡猾、像黄鼠狼一样，
and not setting a clear direction and stuff. I i would say he's a brilliant politician who in very troubled times is actually a very popular king and manages to hold on to his position and yeah i think he actually he faces the same problem that his father had which is that he doesn't have the money yeah exactly which is why he takes the money from the french yes and so rather than kind of you know fight a civil war over it because he's learned from his dad that possibly not the best policy yes and and that's the thing that um that rochester the earl of rochester who's a fabulously scabrous have you got a quotation have you got a quotation i've got the famous one um i mean this is a a poem by Charles II that Rochester wrote, which is so rude that I can't read it because we'll lose all our sponsors. But the concluding
而且没有确定的方向等等。我会说他是一个出色的政治家，在非常动荡的时期，他实际上是一个非常受欢迎的国王，设法保住了自己的地位，而且，是的，我认为他实际上面临着和他父亲一样的问题，那就是他没有钱，是的，没错，这就是为什么他要拿法国人的钱，是的，所以与其为了这事打一场内战——因为他从他父亲那里吸取了教训，那可能不是最好的政策——是的，而且，嗯，罗切斯特，罗切斯特伯爵，一个绝妙的恶毒之徒，你有引文吗？你有引文吗？我有那句著名的，嗯，我的意思是，这是一首查理二世的诗，是罗切斯特写的，粗俗到我没法读，因为那样我们会失去所有的赞助商。但最后
line has the famous phrase, restless he rolls about from whore to whore, a merry monarch, scandalous and poor. And people always remember the merry monarch and the whores and the scandal and things, but it's the poverty, isn't it, really? That underpins a lot of these decisions. But, Tom, he is a merry monarch. I mean, we haven't talked massively about what it is to be a king. And so much of it is about presentation, spectacle, performance, iconography. Charles II ticks all of those boxes.
一句有着那句著名的短语：“不安分地在妓女间辗转，一个风流快活、丑闻不断且贫穷的君王。”人们总是记住那个风流快活的君王、妓女和丑闻之类的，但真正支撑许多这些决定的，其实是贫穷，对吧？但是，汤姆，他确实是一个风流快活的君王。我的意思是，我们没有过多地讨论身为国王意味着什么。很大程度上这关乎展示、奇观、表演、图像学。查理二世完美符合了所有这些标准。
Like Henry VIII, I suppose, or Henry V, you immediately know who he is when you see him. Absolutely. Looks like a Spaniel, basically. Spaniel, yes. Yeah. Well, like a King Charles II Spaniel. Indeed.
就像亨利八世或者亨利五世一样，我想，你一看到他就能立刻认出他是谁。绝对的。长得基本上就像一只西班牙猎犬。西班牙猎犬，是的。对。嗯，就像查理二世国王西班牙猎犬一样。确实。
But he plays the part brilliantly. He's a very canny politician. He doesn't allow his opponents to outsmart him. There's a brilliant book by Jenny Uglow called A Gambling Man, where the motif is about cards and playing cards. And Charles II is a brilliant book by Jenny Uglow called A Gambling Man, where the motif is about cards and playing cards. And Charles II is a brilliant card player. He knows what card to play at the right time. He always stays in the game, unlike his brother James, who was kicked out after only three years, and unlike his father. So of all the stewards, to me, he's, I mean, I know we're fans of James I on this podcast, but he is the most magnetic and in many ways the most impressive.
但他把这个角色扮演得精妙绝伦。他是一个非常精明的政治家。他不允许对手智胜他。珍妮·乌格洛写过一本精彩的书叫《赌徒》，其主题就是扑克牌和纸牌游戏。查理二世——珍妮·乌格洛写过一本精彩的书叫《赌徒》，其主题就是扑克牌和纸牌游戏。而查理二世是一个出色的牌手。他知道在什么时候打出什么牌。他总是能留在牌局中，不像他的弟弟詹姆斯在短短三年后就被踢出局，也不像他的父亲。所以在所有的斯图亚特国王中，对我来说——我知道在这个播客里我们都是詹姆斯一世的粉丝——但他最具磁性，在许多方面也是最令人印象深刻的。
Did he not say about James II, about James, that no one would murder him, Charles, to make him king? I mean, that's quite... Yeah. Quite waggish. Would you say that of all the monarchs
关于詹姆斯二世，他难道没有说过——关于詹姆斯，没有人会为了让他当国王而谋杀查理吗？我的意思是，那相当……是的。相当诙谐。你会不会说，在我们谈论过的所有君王中，
we've talked about, he's the one who's most like Boris? That's very good. Yes, I hadn't thought of that, but he is very Boris-like. But I was just about to say he's probably, of all the monarchs on this podcast, who would you go for a drink with? Charles II's got to be up there.
他是最像鲍里斯的一个？这说得太好了。是的，我之前没想到这一点，但他确实非常像鲍里斯。但我正要说的是，在所有上过这个播客的君王中，如果要选一个人去喝一杯，你可能会选谁？查理二世绝对算一个。
Yeah, you'd be frightened to have a drink with Edward I, wouldn't you? I wouldn't have a drink with... Spill his pint. I wouldn't go for a drink with Richard the Lionheart or something. I mean, he wouldn't even tell me. Smacking you on the... That'd be terrifying. Yeah.
对，跟爱德华一世去喝酒你会觉得害怕，对吧？我才不会跟……洒了他的啤酒。我才不会跟狮心王理查德之类的人去喝酒。我的意思是，他甚至都不会告诉我。一巴掌呼在你……那太吓人了。是的。
Or knoot. I mean... I don't terrifying. Yeah. Or knoot. I mean... I don't know. A beachside cocktail. Beachside barbecue. Yeah. Anyway, we're waffling. Charles II, I think quarterfinals is about right.
或者克努特。我的意思是……我不知道。海滨鸡尾酒。海滨烧烤。是的。不管怎样，我们废话太多了。查理二世，我觉得进四分之一决赛差不多。
I actually expected him to reach the semis because of the sheer magnetism of the Mary Monarch, but he didn't. Crashed out to Elizabeth I. Maybe with a different draw, he could have gone further. However, he didn't get a different draw. So the next monarch to crash out was Edward III. Against Athelstan.
我其实期望他能凭借这位风流君王的绝对磁场打入半决赛，但他没有。败给了伊丽莎白一世。也许换个签运，他能走得更远。然而，他没有抽到好签。所以下一个出局的君王是爱德华三世。对阵阿瑟尔斯坦。
Beaten by Athelstan. So Edward III, he was king for 50 years. I mean, by medieval standards, a colossal, absolutely colossal reign. Well, he was 14 when he became king. He was, wasn't he? So his mum and her partner, her lover. Do that again? That was very good.
被阿瑟尔斯坦击败。所以爱德华三世，他在位50年。我的意思是，以中世纪的标准来看，这是一个庞大无比、绝对庞大无比的统治期。嗯，他当国王时才14岁。他确实是，对吧？所以他的妈妈和她的伴侣、她的情人——
Her lover had disposed of dad, Edward II. Yes, horrifically. Unpleasantly. So we won't go on about it. Oh, you were just about to. Yeah, I was. I was about to say. Well, it's a poker, isn't it?
重来一次？那段太棒了。她的情人已经干掉了爸爸爱德华二世。是的，用极其残忍的方式。极其不愉快。所以我们就不细说了。哦，你正打算说呢。对，我是。我正打算说。嗯，是一根火钳，对吧？
It's the insertion of a poker. That's the claim. But I think that a lot of more serious scrupulous historians say that probably is just a total invention. So we'll say it happened. Yeah. So they're Roger Mortimer and Isabella. And Edward basically turns against them when he grows up a little bit more, doesn't he? And gets rid of them.
就是把火钳捅进去。传闻是这样的。但我认为许多更严肃、一丝不苟的历史学家会说，那可能纯属虚构。所以我们就当它发生过吧。是的。所以他们是罗杰·莫蒂弗和伊莎贝拉。爱德华长大一点后基本上就背叛了他们，对吧？把他们除掉了。
And Roger Mortimer is hanged, I think. So I always loved Edward III. I think we talked about this before the um Conan Doyle's novels about chivalry and the white company white company so Nigel which at the time didn't seem funny to me at all um I absolutely loved them and Edward III is such a kind of dashing figure in them he's a model of heroic king. Do you not think he's slightly, to people who are not experts on the 14th century, Edward III just seems like a slightly
而且罗杰·莫蒂弗被绞死了，我想是的。所以我一直很喜欢爱德华三世。我想我们在之前讨论过这个，嗯，柯南·道尔关于骑士精神和白衣军团的小说——白衣军团，所以还有奈杰尔，当时这对我来说一点也不觉得滑稽，嗯，我超级喜欢它们，爱德华三世在其中是一个非常潇洒的人物，他是英雄国王的楷模。难道你不觉得对于那些对14世纪不太了解的专家来说，爱德华三世有点像一个略显
generic, bearded English king. He fights the French. He's very chivalrous. Yes, but what's wrong with that? Nothing is wrong with that. Surely you're not complaining about that. I'm not complaining, but I find him quite hard to pin down what's distinctive about him.
大众化的、留着胡子的英国国王吗？他跟法国人打仗。他非常具有骑士精神。是的，但这有什么错？这没有什么错。你总不会在抱怨这个吧。我不是在抱怨，但我发现很难确切指出他有什么独特之处。
Well, so he lays claim to the French throne. Yeah. Again, absolutely unjustifiably. But what the hell? They've confiscated Aquitaine, haven't they, the French? That's the pretext for all this, or that's the trigger. Well, no, he's claiming it's all to do with the Salic law. Well, there's a bit of that as well, yeah.
嗯，他宣称对法国王位拥有主权。是的。同样，这绝对是毫无道理的。但管他呢？法国人已经没收了阿基坦，不是吗？这就是这一切的借口，或者说导火索。哦，不，他声称这一切都与萨利克法有关。嗯，也有这方面的原因，是的。
It's said through the female line, which according to French law doesn't count. And he says it does. Anyway, it's all just an excuse to have a massive romp. So the English defeat the French at the naval battle of Sluis. And then they have the battle of Crecy where they unleash the longbow. Great moment. And it's kind of heartwarming. And then they have the Battle of Crecy where they unleash the longbow. Great moment. So, and it's kind of heartwarming. It's the union between stirring chivalrous knights and kind of horny handed Sandbrook figures.
据说这是通过女性血统继承的，根据法国法律这不算数。而他坚称算数。不管怎样，这统统只是进行一场宏大狂欢的借口。于是英国人在斯鲁伊斯海战中击败了法国人。然后他们进行了克雷西战役，在那里他们释放了长弓。伟大的时刻。这让人感觉暖心。然后他们进行了克雷西战役，在那里他们释放了长弓。伟大的时刻。所以，这让人感觉暖心。这是激情四射的骑士与粗糙手掌的桑德布鲁克人物之间的结合。
Yeoman. Yeoman, I think is the word. With their longbows. And it's all utterly chivalrous. And the Black Prince, his son's it's his first big battle he's coming under pressure people come and ask edward the third should we go to his rescue and he says no let the boy win his spurs and he does win his spurs great moment and and um he he kills the blind king of bohemia uh and takes his um his uh, his motto, which is still the Prince of Wales motto to this day.
自耕农。我想“自耕农”就是这个词。带着他们的长弓。这一切都完全充满骑士精神。黑太子，他的儿子，这是他的第一场大战，他承受着压力，人们跑来问爱德华三世，我们应不应该去救他，他说不，让这孩子自己去赢得马刺。而他真的赢得了马刺，伟大的时刻。并且，嗯，他——他杀死了盲眼波西米亚国王，嗯，采用了他的，嗯，他的，他的座右铭，至今仍是威尔士亲王的座罗格。
And it's all utterly chivalrous. And then due course, the Black Prince wins the Battle of Poitiers as well in exactly the same way. And he actually captures the French king. Edward III has captured both the Scottish and the French king. You know, it's all, you know, what's not to like? It's all utterly chivalrous and heroic. However, there are two massive downsides. One is the black death
这一切都完全充满骑士精神。随后不久，黑太子用完全相同的方式赢得了普瓦捷战役的胜利。而且他 실제로 俘虏了法国国王。爱德华三世既俘虏了苏格兰国王，又俘虏了法国国王。你知道，这一切，你知道，有什么不喜欢的呢？这一切都完全充满骑士精神，充满英雄主义。然而，有两个巨大的缺点。一个是黑死病，
which obviously is not good news that's not really his fault though i mean you can't no it's not you know he should have locked down earlier well but i mean it's like covid kind of interrupting the sports fixtures that it interrupts the hundred years war so they have to kind of stop the hundred years war um you know we'll play it in kind of empty stadium behind closed doors yes behind closed doors so the battle of cressy's before the black death and battle party a comes you know, we'll play it in kind of empty stadium. Behind closed doors. Yes, behind closed doors. So the Battle of Crecy is before the Black Death and Battle of Poitiers comes, you know, they're emerging out of lockdown.
这显然不是什么好消息，但其实这也不是他的错，我的意思是，你不能——不，不是的，你知道的，他应该更早地进行封锁。好吧，但这有点像新冠疫情打断了体育赛事一样，它打断了百年战争，所以他们不得不暂停百年战争，嗯，你知道的，我们将在空无一人的体育场里闭门比赛，是的，闭门比赛。所以克雷西战役是在黑死病之前，普瓦捷战役来的时候，你知道，他们正在从封锁中走出来。
But the other thing that stands against Edward III is that he ends up very kind of senile and under the thumb of a sinister mistress called Alice Peres. Alice Peres. Is she sinister or is that just put about by her? Yeah, it's all put
但另一个不利于爱德华三世的因素是，他最终变得非常老朽，并且受制于一个名叫爱丽丝·佩雷斯的阴险情妇。爱丽丝·佩雷斯。她是阴险还是这只是别人对她的造谣？是的，这全都是造谣——
about i don't know i mean but um there's the definite sense that actually a bit like with henry v the whole idea of invading france is basically a disastrous idea and that no matter how successful some of the battles might be the whole thing in the long run will lead to a kind of meltdown which is what happens in England, because peasants revolt, misery. But, Tom, it's a very important reign, isn't it, because it sees the triumph of chivalry, it sees English being used in law courts and in Parliament. Chaucer. Chaucer, of course.
我不知道，我的意思是，但是，确实有一种明确的感觉，实际上就像亨利五世一样，入侵法国的整个主意基本上是一个灾难性的主意，无论其中某些战斗取得多大的成功，从长远来看，整件事都会导致某种崩溃，这就是英格兰发生的事情，因为农民起义，苦难不断。但是，汤姆，这是一个非常重要的统治期，不是吗？因为它见证了骑士精神的胜利，见证了英语在法庭和议会中的使用。乔叟。当然还有乔叟。
So it feels like, is it wrong to see it as a, well, how can it be a golden age when a third of the population has been killed by the Black Death? But people do see it as, I mean, obviously, Sir Arthur Conan Doyle saw it as a bit of a golden age, didn't he? I mean, I think it kind of merges with a vague, hazy idea of King Arthur. Yes. Prasar said, didn't he, that Edward III was such a king
所以感觉像，如果把这看作是一个黄金时代，难道有什么不对吗？好吧，当三分之一的人口被黑死病夺去生命时，怎么能算是黄金时代呢？但人们确实把它看作——显而易见，柯南·道尔爵士把它看作是一个有点像黄金时代的时期，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为这有点与对亚瑟王的模糊、朦胧的想法融合在了一起。是的。普拉瑟曾说过，不是吗？爱德华三世是一位自亚瑟王时代以来从未见过的伟大国王。
as had not been seen since the days of King Arthur. Yes, and there's the whole... He establishes the Order of the Garter. Yeah. Oni, swaki, mali, pons, evil be to he who evil thinks. Honey, you've lost your garter, as 1066 transcribes it. So I think there's a kind of a general, a bit like Henry V, there's a kind of aureate glow around it.
是的，还有整个……他创立了嘉德勋章。是的。“恶意自其心生，心怀恶念者必受其惩。”honey，你弄丢了嘉德带，正如1066年抄本所记录的那样。所以我认为有一种普遍的，有点像亨利五世那样，周围有一种金色光芒的光环。
But also when I think of it, I think of it as, so if I'm kind of imagining Edward III's reign, I'm thinking a bright, sunny morning, glorious midday, and then the clouds start to roll in. And plague. And plague, and it all goes wrong. So the historian Norman Cantor said of Edward III, he was an avaricious and sadistic thug.
但每当我想到它时，我也会这样想：如果我在脑海中想象爱德华三世的统治，我想象的是一个明亮、阳光灿烂的早晨，辉煌的正午，然后乌云开始聚集。还有瘟疫。还有瘟疫，一切都搞砸了。所以历史学家诺曼·坎特对爱德华三世的评价是：他是一个贪婪而嗜血的恶棍。
I'm sure he was. But that's what people wanted, isn't it? That's the mark of great kingship in the medieval period, to booty for your mates and bashing the French. Which, again, I think kind of highlights the way that in this World Cup, every monarch has to be judged by the standards of the age in which they rule. And I suppose ultimately what's being judged is whether they're iconic. Yeah, that's probably true.
我确信他确实如此。但这正是人们所期望的，不是吗？那是中世纪伟大君王的标准，为你的伙伴们掠夺战利品并痛击法国人。这再次突显了这样一点：在这场世界杯中，必须根据他们统治时代的标准来评判每一位君王。我想最终评判的是他们是否具有标志性意义。是的，这大概是真的。
So talking of avaricious and sadistic thugs, we're now onto the semifinals. And the first semifinals for Athelstan, it was a sort of, you know, it was an Anglo-Saxon-Norman rematch, wasn't it? It was Athelstan against William the Conqueror. At that point, when I saw Jonathan Wilson make the draw, it was blindingly obvious to me that Athelstan would make the final because William the Conqueror is a man who is respected but I think fair to say not loved
说到贪婪和嗜血的恶棍，我们现在进入了半决赛。阿瑟尔斯坦的第一场半决赛，这是一场盎格鲁-撒克逊人与诺曼人的重赛，对吧？那是阿瑟尔斯坦对阵征服者威廉。当时，当我看到乔纳森·威尔逊排出这个对阵时，我极其清楚地意识到阿瑟尔斯坦将进入决赛，因为征服者威廉是一个受到尊重但坦白说并不被喜爱的人——
no and I'm amazed actually that he got this far and I think it's really interesting the fact he did get this far what it says about um well about how Hastings is viewed, actually. But he's been rewarded here. Nobody, I mean, if you asked English people in the streets, do you wish the Anglo-Saxons had won the Battle of Hastings? They would probably say yes, wouldn't they? The Anglo-Saxons are romantic. They are the underdogs in the Battle of Hastings.
不，而且我很惊讶他竟然能走到这一步，我觉得他能走到这一步真的很有趣，这说明了——嗯，关于黑斯ティング斯战役是如何被看待的，其实。但他在这里得到了回报。没有人——我的意思是，如果你问街上的英国人，你希望盎格鲁-撒克逊人在黑斯廷斯战役中获胜吗？他们可能会说“是”，对吧？盎格鲁-撒克逊人很浪漫。他们在黑斯廷斯战役中处于弱势。
But he is being, he's the sort of Margaret Thatcher of this competition. Yeah, but if you said, we lost the Battle of Hastings. Yeah. I don't think people would say that. I mean, you might say, you know, an English person might say, we won the Battle of Waterloo or we won the Battle of Britain. But would we say we lost the Battle of Hastings? I don't think we would because I think we recognise that actually what William brought was so formative for England that it's become a part of what it is to be English. And obviously that's the case with the monarchy.
但他正在被——他是这场比赛中的玛格丽特·撒切尔式人物。是的，但如果你说，我们输掉了黑斯廷斯战役。是的。我不认为人们会这么说。我的意思是，你可能会说，嗯，一个英国人可能会说，我们赢得了滑铁卢战役，或者我们赢得了不列颠之战。但我们会说我们输掉了黑斯廷斯战役吗？我想我们不会，因为我认为我们认识到，威廉带来的一切对英格兰来说是如此具有塑造性，以至于它已经成为“英格兰性”的一部分。显然君主制也是如此。
The monarchy is more Norman, perhaps, than it is Anglo-Saxon. You mean because the Anglo-Saxon monarchy was more, what, was more elective, more consensual, more low-key? No, no, no. The antiquity and the dignity of the Anglo-Saxon monarchy is very, very important to William. It's part of the loot of England. It's part of what he wants. The fact that it is, dare I say, sacral.
君主制可能比盎格鲁-撒克逊时期更具诺曼色彩。你是说因为盎格鲁-撒克逊君主制更——怎么说，更具选举性、更具协商性、更低调？不，不，不。盎格鲁-撒克逊君主制的古老和尊严对威廉来说非常非常重要。这是征服英格兰的战利品的一部分。这是他想要的东西的一部分。它——我敢说——具有神圣性。
You become an... As Duke of Normandy, he's not an anointed ruler. As King of England, he is. So that's very important. But the fact that basically we date kings from 1066. Yeah. So we've said that, you know, there are three King Edwards before Edward I, but he is the first Edward. Yeah.
你成为一个……作为诺曼底公爵，他不是一个受过涂油礼的统治者。作为英格兰国王，他是。所以这非常重要。但事实上，我们基本上是从1066年开始计算国王的。是的。所以我们说过，在爱德华一世之前有三位爱德华国王，但他才是第一位爱德华。是的。
I think it reflects the fact that essentially we see William as the founder of the English monarchy in a way that obviously is ahistorical, but reflects a kind of deep truth of just how significant William's reign is. And that therefore, in a sense, he is seen as not just a kind of alien invader, perhaps in the way that Cnut is, but as a legitimate king of England. Yeah, I think that's true. It's partly because of the Doomsday Book, isn't it? Because the Doomsday Book is seen as one of the foundational texts of English government and of English identity, actually. Also, I think, I mean, he, yeah, he, the kind of the castles that he and his followers planned across England, they've kind of also become representative of the Middle Ages for people. Yeah.
我认为这反映了这样一个事实：本质上，我们将威廉视为英格兰君主制的奠基人，虽然这种看法显然是不符合历史的，但它反映了一种深层的真相，即威廉的统治是多么意义重大。因此，从某种意义上说，他不仅被视为一种外来入侵者（就像克努特那样），而是被视为一个合法的英格兰国王。是的，我想这是真的。这部分是因为《末日审判书》，对吧？因为《末日审判书》被视为英格兰政府和英格兰身份认同的奠基文本之一。另外，我认为，他——是的，他和他的追随者在英格兰各地规划的城堡，在某种程度上也成为了人们心中中世纪的代表。是的。
So if you have a castle and the great cathededrals of which darren would be the the kind of the first that these for people these for most of us i think are kind of visual symbols of what england is and because we don't have anglo-saxon equivalents that's another reason i think why the anglo-saxon period is so much more shadowy yeah i'm sure i think that's a that that's very true i think there's also with william though there's the issue of his should we say his bastardy so he was called william the bastard because he was illegitimate and he seemed to have behaved like a bastard as a bastard wasn't yeah exactly harrying northerners um smiting people well again so so so um a definite sense from from twitter engagements that people in the North have not forgotten. Yeah.
所以如果你有一座城堡，还有达勒姆那样的大教堂，这些对人们来说——对我们大多数人来说，我认为它们是英格兰是什么的视觉符号。正因为我们没有盎格鲁-撒克逊版本的对应物，我认为这就是为什么盎格鲁-撒克逊时期如此模糊不清的另一个原因。是的，我确信，我认为这——这非常真实。但我认为，对于威廉，还有一个关于他的——我们该怎么说——私生子身份的问题。所以他被称为“征服者威廉”是因为他私生子的身份，他似乎也表现得像个私生子，作为一个私生子，对吧？没错，对北部地区的残酷镇压……打击人们。好吧，同样地——所以——来自推特互动的明确感觉是，北方人民并没有忘记。
I mean, it was a kind of near-genocidal repression of rebellion in the North. I mean, can you make a case for him and say he's ruthless and that's what he has to be? I mean, he lives in a ruthless age where you win by the sword and if you don't, you die. I mean, that's surely the case you'd make, that he's a strong leader, and any successful regime in the 11th century, you have to be really stern. Yes, I think so. But even his own followers, so Audre Vitalis, who's very admiring of him generally,
我的意思是，这是对北方叛乱近乎种族灭绝式的镇压。我的意思是，你能为他辩护并说他冷酷无情，而这就是他必须成为的样子吗？我的意思是，他生活在一个冷酷无情的时代，你靠剑赢得一切，如果不这样做，你就会死。我的意思是，你一定会这样为他辩护，他是一个强硬的领导者，在11世纪任何一个成功的政权中，你都必须非常严厉。是的，我也这么认为。但连他自己的追随者——比如奥德里克·维塔利斯，他通常对威廉极为赞赏——
says of the harrowing of the North that with this, I cannot justify this. This was a terrible thing. So even by the standards of his own time, he's seen as repressive, autocratic. Yeah, and I think the great abbey he builds on the site of Hastings, the Battle of Hastings, is also a monument to that because that's built as a way to try and expiate the crime that he committed in killing so many people.
却在谈到对北方的残酷镇压时说：“对此，我无法辩护。这是一件可怕的事情。”所以，即使以他那个时代的标准来看，他也被视为压制性的、专制的。是的，我认为他在黑斯廷斯战役遗址上建造的大修道院也是这种心态的纪念碑，因为那是为了试图赎罪，洗刷他因杀害如此多的人而犯下的罪行。
So I think that kind of strain, which you also have in Henry V, the strange combination of kind of martial brutality and piety you absolutely get in William. And neither of those are very popular qualities. But that's why the story that everybody enjoys about William is his funeral. So he's died in Normandy and his body is sort of expanded with gas, hasn't it? Isn't that right? That he's sort of swollen.
所以我认为这种倾向——你在亨利五世身上也能看到——军事残暴与虔诚的奇怪结合，在威廉身上绝对是存在的。而这两者都不是非常受欢迎的品质。但这就是为什么每个人都津津乐道关于威廉的那个故事是他的葬礼。所以他在诺曼底去世了，他的尸体由于气体膨胀而鼓起来了，不是吗？是不是这样？他的身体肿胀了。
They're trying to shove his body into the coffin. It's basically too small for it. He's become an enormous fellow. They shove him in and he bursts and his entrails fall out with a terrible stench. That's right. And everybody doesn't really run out of the church in horror or something? So it's a very undignified end.
他们试图把他的尸体塞进棺材里。那棺材对他的身体来说基本上太小了。他变得非常巨大。他们把他硬塞进去，结果他爆裂了，内脏伴随着可怕的恶臭流了出来。没错。然后所有人是不是都吓得逃出了教堂什么的？所以这是一个非常不体面的结局。
Harold Godwinson's Revenge, I think we can call it. And he's buried next to his wife, Matilda, who everyone says is very small, but actually wasn't. Wasn't she? No, she wasn't, apparently. Why do people say it then?
我想我们可以称之为“哈罗德·戈德温森的复仇”。他被埋葬在妻子玛蒂尔达旁边，大家都说她身材非常娇小，但实际上并不是。她不是吗？不，显然她不是。
Because their graves got rifled in the French Revolution. And I think bits have got kind of lost. So people thought she was basically four foot, she was absolutely midget. Well, they just don't realise that the rest of her is missing. Well, they've kind of gone back and worked out that actually she was of absolutely average height.
那为什么人们这么说？因为他们的坟墓在法国大革命期间被洗劫了。我想有些碎块可能丢失了。所以人们以为她基本上只有四英尺高，是个绝对的侏儒。好吧，他们只是没有意识到她剩下的部分不见了。好吧，他们后来回去研究并计算出，实际上她拥有绝对标准的平均身高。
Okay, well, this is fascinating stuff. An average-heighted woman, not a small one. Right. So we have one other semi-final loser, don't we? So we had the Elizabeth Derby, Elizabeth I against Elizabeth II. Yet again, Elizabeth I won an absolutely crushing victory.
好吧，这真是太迷人了。一个中等身高的女性，而不是一个小个子。好勒。所以我们还有另一位半决赛失利者，对吧？我们有伊丽莎白德比：伊丽莎白一世对阵伊丽莎白二世。伊丽莎白一世再次取得了压倒性的胜利。
And Elizabeth II... Now, you said that she'd done nothing. I mean, she hasn't done nothing, but she's done little by comparison with her previous... But she's done nothing in a positive way. hasn't done nothing, but she's done little by comparison with her previous. She's had to make fewer choices. She's done nothing in a positive way. Hasn't she? She's been positively boring.
而伊丽莎白二世……现在，你曾说过她什么也没做。我的意思是，她并不是什么都没做，但与她之前的人相比，她做的事很少……但在积极的方面她什么也没做。并不是什么都没做，但与她之前的人相比，她做的事很少。她不得不做出的选择更少。在积极的方面她什么也没做。难道不是吗？她无聊透顶。
Yes. She's been very canny in her boringness, I think. And she has, you know, God, I mean, I do so many kind of Channel 5 talking head things about the 20th century monarchy. My heart really isn't in saying yet again. Well, just what's your take on that? Saying yet again, you know, saying yes again you know she's managed the she's navigated the shoals oh yeah great friends with harold wilson you know silver
是的。我认为她在无聊这件事上非常精明。而且她——天哪，我的意思是，我做了那么多关于20世纪君主制的第五频道（Channel 5）谈话节目。我的心实在不在于再次说……好吧，你对此有什么看法？再次说……再次说，你知道的，她设法处理了……她驾驭了各种暗礁。哦，是的，和哈罗德·维尔逊是好朋友，你知道，白金禧年……老实说，我都能背下来了。在梦里我都能听到自己的声音在单调地重复这些东西。我的经纪人如果听到我这么说，一定会气疯的——把自己推出（你知道的）2027年在第四频道（Channel 4）播出的“伊丽莎白二世的101个高光时刻”之类的节目。不管怎样，你想聊聊女王吗，汤姆？嗯，我认为——所以如果我们说我们必须用这样的标准来评判君主——如果我们以他们生活的时代的标准来评判他们的成功，我会说，有理由认为伊丽莎白二世是英国历史上最成功的君主。但你的评判标准完全不同，对吧？
jubilee i could do it to be honest i just hit my own voice droning in my sleep seeing this stuff my agent will be absolutely livid with me for saying this uh doing myself out of you know 101 top elizabeth the second moments on Channel 4 in 2027 or whatever. Anyway, do you want to talk about the Queen, Tom? Well, I think – so if we say we have to judge monarchs by – if we're judging their success by the standards of the age in which they live, I would say that it's a case for saying Elizabeth II is the most successful monarch Britain's ever had. But you're judging by such different standards, aren't you?
是的，当然。所以她没有改变英国历史的进程。她没有击败法国人，没有改变宗教信仰之类的。但她作为立宪君主的角色一直是作为国家的象征——
Yeah, of course. So she hasn't changed the course of English history. She hasn't defeated the French, hasn't changed the religion or anything like that. But her role as constitutional monarch has been to serve as a figurehead
你应该去拍这些纪录片，而不是我。我知道我应该去。因为对我来说，我其实以前真的没怎么想过这一点。所以对我来说，这一切都是新鲜的。你可以在旁边对我冷嘲热讽。但你会说，她统治的几十年里，经历了一场又一场显著的动荡。很难想象还有哪个时期，人们对道德或伦理的理解发生了如此剧烈的变化。不，我们之前讨论过这一点，我的意思是，那是文化上的剧烈动荡。拜托，我的意思是，宗教改革、对性的态度、对性别的态度、对种族的态度——
for the nation. You should do these documentaries instead of me. I know I should. Because for me, I haven't actually really thought about this before. So for me, it's all fresh. You can just kind of barrack me from the side. But what you'd say about the decades of her reign is that they have been remarkably convulsive. It's hard to think of a time where people's understanding of of say morals or ethics have changed so radically no we've discussed that before i mean that's that's culturally convulsive come on i mean the reformation attitudes to sex to gender yeah to race
发生了如此深刻的变化。而且我认为有趣的是，它们发生了如此深刻的变化。而且我认为有趣的是，它们发生的方式在客观上应该对世袭君主制的概念具有极大的破坏性。因为那种权威和特权压迫历史上处于弱势群体的观念已经变得绝对不行了。
have have changed so profoundly and i think also what's interesting is that they have changed so profoundly. And I think also what's interesting is that they have changed in ways that objectively should be very destabilising to the idea of a hereditary monarchy. Because the idea of a kind of authority and privilege oppressing those who historically have been underprivileged has become an absolute no-no i
我的意思是，正是这种观念推动了女权主义革命、向同性恋群体赋予基本上等同于异性恋群你的权利、对种族主义的焦虑——所有这些，你本以为都会对以下观念构成威胁……对种族主义的焦虑，所有这些，你本以为都会对以下事实构成威胁：我们的国家元首统治是因为她传承自一个最终可以追溯到奥丁的漫长君主世袭序列。人们会继续接受这一点，这并不是理所当然的。我认为大体上人们还是接受了，所以按这个标准，我会说伊丽莎白的成就令人震惊。我认为她之所以成功，不仅是因为她接受了“无聊”基本上就是她的工作，还因为她真的
mean that's what kind of has driven the feminist revolution the um uh the giving to to uh gay people of you know basically rights equivalent to heterosexual people the um anxieties about racism um that all of these you would thought would be threatening to the idea of uh racism, that all of these you would have thought would be threatening to the idea of the fact that our head of state rules by virtue of her descent from a long line of monarchs who ultimately go back to Woden. There's nothing obvious about the fact that people would continue to accept this. And I think by and large people people do and so by that standard i would say that that elizabeth's achievement has been astonishing and i think the reason why she's been successful isn't just because she's you know she's accepted that being boring is basically what her job has been but also that she really
坚信这一点。她对待这件事非常非常严肃。我认为，对于君主制的成功来说，绝对至关重要的一点是，君主本身必须极其认真地对待他们正在做的事情。你不能成为一个轻浮的君主，对吧？你现在不能成为那种查理二世类型的君主。你必须严肃对待。你必须对此满腔热忱。而伊丽莎白二世确实如此。她真的认为自己是由上帝指派的，我想是的。这让我怀疑在她之后，这个制度还能维持多久。
believes it she takes it very very seriously and i think that that it's absolutely essential for the success of monarchy that monarchs themselves take what they're doing very, very seriously. You couldn't be a flippant monarch, could you? You couldn't be a kind of Charles II type monarch now. You have to take it seriously. You have to be earnest about it. And Elizabeth II really does. She really does think that she's been appointed by God, I think. And that's what makes me wonder whether the institution will last very long after her.
我一向认为它会维持下去。好吧，让我们不要陷入对未来的预测中。嗯，我要说的是，我们讨论过的另一件事情是，对于在位的国王来说，孩子们可能会带来麻烦。我认为查理很好，但比如安德鲁就是一个大震撼。我认为他就像人们接受君主制核心的一个巨大毒瘤，因为一个愚蠢且自以为是的色狼对任何国王来说都不是什么光彩的形象，你知道的，即使我认为甚至……充斥着自以为是。我知道，但这通常不会带来好结果。所以我认为安德鲁提醒了人们君主制可能会给你带来什么。是的。
I always think it will. I think, well, let's not get into prognostications of the future. Well, what I would say is one of the other things that we've talked about is how children can be problematic for reigning kings. I think Charles is fine but i think for instance andrew is a shocker i think he's like a kind of great cancer at the heart of people's acceptance of monarchy because a kind of thick entitled perv is not a good look for any king you know even i think even has been littered with thinking titles. I know, but generally they haven't gone down well. So I think Andrew is a kind of reminder to people
我想说的是，在某种程度上与你意见一致：首先，女王可能是英国历史上最受欢迎的君主，因为通过她自己，她并不是一个分裂性人物。我的意思是，她不必做出以前更有权力的君主不得不做出的那种分裂性选择。
of what monarchy can serve up to you. Yeah. I think what I would say in sort of agreement with you is, first of all, the Queen is probably the most popular monarch Britain has ever had because by her, she's not divisive. I mean, she hasn't had to make the divisive choices that a previous, more powerful monarch would have had to have made.
所以她的首相们可能具有分裂性，但她没有。而且她把君主制留在了比1950年代以后任何其他君主统治下看起来更坚实的基础之上。很难想象怎么会有人把它留在一个更好的状态中，可以说是这样。所以，是的，但她确实很无聊。
So her prime ministers have been divisive, but she hasn't. And she probably leaves the monarchy on firmer foundations than would have seemed possible under any other post-1950s monarch. It's hard to imagine how somebody could have left it in a better state, as it were. So, yes, but she is boring.
我的意思是，你之前说过这部分是一场关于图像学和标志性的大赛。我认为女王是具有标志性的。嗯，她确实具有标志性，但她的标志性体现在稳定、严肃、责任感和职责上。这些都是令人钦佩的品质，但并不性感。但她是全球性的标志性人物。她确实是。
I mean, you were saying this is partly a tournament about iconography and about are you iconic? I think the Queen is iconic. Well, she is iconic, but she's iconic for stability, for seriousness, for responsibility, for duty. All admirable things, but not sexy things. But she's globally iconic. She is.
我的意思是，如果你提到女王，你知道，有很多事情……正如你和我前几天在播客之外讨论的那样，阿瑟尔斯坦的结果竟然被印尼的一些新闻网站报道了，说“女王没有赢”。我的意思是，他们为什么要在乎？他们在乎是因为女王具有标志性，被视为英国性的象征。
I mean, if you say the queen, you know, there are lots of things. Well, as you and I were talking about just the other day, not on the podcast, the fact that this, the Athelstan result was being reported in kind of Indonesian news websites saying, you know, the queen didn't win. I mean, why would they care? They care because the Queen is iconic and is seen as a symbol of Britishness.
实际上，成为国家的象征正是君主制……我的意思是，这就是成功的标志，对吧？而且我认为她还充当了对人们的一种活生生的抚慰，让他们知道（你知道的）这个国家依然是那个国家，英国依然是英国，尽管人们担心它可能已经不是了。
And actually becoming a symbol of the nation is what the monarchy... I mean, that's the sign of success, isn't it? And I think also that she has served as a kind of living reassurance to people that, you know, the country is still the country, that Britain is still Britain, even as people worry that they're not.
我们快要沦为制作第五频道的皇室纪录片了。是的，我们快成了。所以我们继续吧。所以，这就是那两位半决赛选手，然后决赛是伊丽莎白和阿瑟尔斯坦，伊丽莎白一世。我们在本系列的早期确实和特雷西·博曼一起录制过一期关于伊丽莎白一世的播客，但让我们来稍微聊聊那场对决——阿瑟尔斯坦对阵伊丽莎白一世。所以那——我的意思是，他们是象征，他们都是英格兰性的象征。阿瑟尔斯坦显然稍微有点像是“懂行之人的选择”，是那些对历史真正感兴趣的人会喜欢的那种，有点像盎格鲁-撒克逊人，部分原因在于他们不太为人所知，他们有点与众不同，他们不属于英国历史中那些普遍且略显乏味的陈词滥调，而伊丽莎白一世绝对是英国历史所有陈词滥调的核心，不是吗？抗击西班牙无敌舰队、莎士比亚、德雷克，诸如此类。但归根结底，如果这次民意调查是由普通公众而不是“历史剩余价值”听众完成的，伊丽莎白一世肯定会赢，对吧？
We're in danger of degenerating into a Channel 5 royal documentary. Yeah, we are. So let's move on. So we've got, so they were the two semi-finalists and then the final was Elizabeth and Athelstan, Elizabeth I. We did do a podcast about Elizabeth I
我想是的，是的，我想是的。我的意思是，你可以从某些新闻媒体报道它时的难以置信的语气中看出这一点，有些新闻媒体就是这样报道的。我的意思是，我只想说，嗯，我——我——我不认为任何人有任何理由去讨厌阿瑟尔斯坦——维京人，我不是——我的意思是，这一切都太古老了，以至于连，你知道的，
with Tracy Borman earlier in this series, but let's just talk a bit about that clash the athelstan against elizabeth i so that's i mean there's their symbols they're both symbols of englishness athelstan was obviously a slightly sort of connoisseur's choice of you know people who are really interested in history kind of like the anglo-saxons partly because they're not well known because they are bit different, they're not part of the general sort of slightly tiresome clichés of English history, whereas Elizabeth I is absolutely the centre of all the clichés of English history, isn't she? Defying the Spanish Armada, Shakespeare, Drake,
威尔士人也不会抱怨他曾经对他们吆五喝六。苏格兰人也不会抱怨他曾经入侵苏格兰。我的意思是，这一切都太久远了。我想没有人会对他的感情强烈到去讨厌他。曾经有人相当强烈地讨厌伊丽莎白。但那肯定有点像表演性质的，对吧？我的意思是，伊丽莎白一世大体上并不是一个极其具有分裂性的君主。好吧，再次说明，简·奥斯汀就是这样。
all of this sort of stuff. But ultimately, I think if this poll had been done by the general public rather than the rest of its history listeners, surely Elizabeth I would have won, wouldn't she? I think so, yeah, I think so. I mean mean you can sort of tell that in the incredulity with which news outlets some news outlets reported it i mean all i would say is that um that i i i don't think that anyone has any reason to hate athelstan vikings i don't i mean i it's it's all such ancient history that even, you know,
是的。苏格兰女王玛丽的超级粉丝。是的。她称伊丽莎白是“人类的耻辱”。“一切舒适的毁灭者”。“对托付给她的信任的虚伪背叛”。至少这并没有被过度夸大。没有。好吧，简·奥斯汀以其夸张的语言而闻名。
the Welsh aren't going to complain that he kind of bossed them around. The Scots aren't going to complain that he invaded Scotland. I mean, this is all so long ago. No one feels strongly enough about him, I think, to dislike him. There have been people who have quite strongly disliked Elizabeth. But that's surely a bit sort of performative, isn't it? I mean, Elizabeth I is not, by and large, a terribly divisive monarch. Well, again, I was Jane Austen.
而且她是一位经历了一场激进宗教动荡、分裂时期的女王。她的伟大成就，是将都铎政权与爱国的英国身份认同结合起来——嗯，这确实是——我认为这在今天已经以一种相当具有凝聚力的方式在消退了，汤姆，在一个动荡不安的时代——我的意思是，你考虑一下之前发生的事情，然后是接下来的一百年里将要发生的事情——完全如此，完全如此。但我的意思是，如果你是，比方说，天主教徒或爱尔兰人——或者两者皆是——你就不一定会把伊丽莎白一世视为一个伟大的传奇人物。不，你不会，但你不能否认她是一个极其高效的人物。我没有——我没有否认，我只是说有理由——不，不，不，但我是说，
Yeah. Huge fan of Mary Queen of Scots. Yeah. A disgrace to humanity, she called Elizabeth. The destroyer of all comfort. The deceitful betrayer of trust reposed in her. At least that's not massively overstated. No. Well, Jane Austen, famous for her excessive language.
甚至连她的批评者——甚至连她的批评者都不能否认她是一个 brilhante（出色的）机会主义者、一个杰出的政治幸存者。作为一名女性，在这样一个充满宗教动荡、面临西班牙敌意——西方世界最大超级大国的敌意——的时期，她面对的挑战绝对是巨大的。她迎难而上。扮演处女女王的角色，扮演格洛丽安娜和英格兰性的化身，这是一场极其、极其精彩的宣传政变。
And she is a queen during a period of radical religious upheaval, of division. Her great achievement is to joinantism with patriotic english identity uh that is that is something i think that is fading now in a reasonably unifying way actually tom at a time of enormous turmoil i mean you consider that would have proceeded and then what was to follow in the next hundred years completely completely but i'm just saying that that it is possible if you are say i don't know catholic or irish uh or both that you don't necessarily see elizabeth first as necessarily a great figure no you don't but you cannot deny she's a colossally effective figure i'm not i'm not denying it but i'm just saying that there are reasons no no no but i'm saying
嗯，我们说过这完全取决于你是否具有标志性。我的意思是，她字面意义上就是标志性的。她在情感上有点取代了圣母玛利亚，你知道的，那种象征意义。处女女王，没错。英格兰历来以对玛利亚的崇拜而闻名。她就是——你知道的，英国人对圣母玛利亚的崇拜曾广受赞誉。那是沃尔辛厄姆教堂吗？
even her critics even her critics couldn't deny that she is a brilliant opportunist, a brilliant political survivor. The challenges facing her are absolutely colossal as a woman in a time of such religious turmoil, with Spanish hostility, the hostility of the greatest superpower, certainly in the Western world. She is up against it. And playing the Virgin Queen part and sort of Gloriana and the incarnation of Englishness is a brilliant, brilliant propaganda coup.
甚至连她的批评者都无法否认，她是一个极其聪明的机会主义者，一个出色的政治幸存者。作为一个女性，在这样一个宗教动荡、面临西班牙敌意——这个西方世界最大超级大国的敌意——的时代，她所面临的挑战绝对是巨大的。她处境艰难。而扮演童贞女王的角色、某种程度上的“光荣女王”以及英格兰精神的化身，是一次绝妙绝伦的政治宣传成功。
Well, we've said that this is all about whether you're iconic. I mean, she's literally iconic. She kind of replaces the Virgin Mary in the affections, you know, the symbolism. The Virgin Queen, exactly. England was famously devoted to Mary. She was, you know, the devotion of the English to the Virgin Mary was celebrated. Is it Walsingham Church?
嗯，我们说过这完全取决于你是否具有标志性。我的意思是，她字面意义上就是个标志。在人们的情感和象征意义上，她有点取代了圣母玛利亚。童贞女王，完全正确。英格兰曾以对玛利亚的虔诚著称。你知道的，英格兰人对圣母玛利亚的崇拜曾闻名遐迩。那是沃尔辛厄姆教堂吗？
Yes, yeah, Our Lady of Walsingham. And Elizabeth brilliantly, brilliantly kind of usurps that role. She steps into the Virgin's shoes, if you like. So she's absolutely literally iconic in that sense yeah um which is why she reached the final why she was the number one seed and why i think it was a big you know global press attention focused on the stunning result of this what i think has been our best world cup well it's certainly been uh the one that uh people have got most excited about i have a little bit of a soft spot for the Prime Minister's World Cup.
是的，沃尔辛厄姆圣母。伊丽莎白非常巧妙地篡夺了那个角色。如果你愿意的话，她步入了圣母的鞋子。所以在某种意义上她绝对是标志性的，这也是为什么她进入了决赛，为什么她是头号种子，为什么我认为这是一场引起全球媒体广泛关注的惊人结果，我认为这是我们最好的一届世界杯，当然也是人们最兴奋的一届。我对首相世界杯也有一点偏爱。
I have to say I enjoyed that one. But do you think these things have – they're an interesting insight into the minds of history buffs, I think. Don't you think that's fair? I guess so, yeah. Yeah, certainly an interesting insight into the minds of our listeners on whom we so depend. That's very nice to end on a...
我不得不说我很喜欢那一届。但你认为这些事情——它们是对历史迷心理的一个有趣洞察，我想。你不觉得这很公平吗？我想是的。是的，这无疑是对我们如此依赖的听众心理的一个有趣洞察。以这样的方式结束真是太好了……
But I don't think we particularly influenced it. Oh, come on. What, you were plugging your book on Athelstan from start to finish? No, I wasn't. I might have mentioned it once, I think. I think you mentioned it more than once. I wasn't as partisan as I was in the notorious ISIS anubis.
但我不认为我们特别去影响了它。哦，得了吧。什么，你从头到尾都在推销你的关于埃塞尔斯坦的书？不，我没有。我想我可能只提过一次。我觉得你不止提了一次。我可没有像在那个臭名昭著的伊西斯阿努比斯之战里那样带有党派偏见。
No, well, that was nice that we didn't have a repeat of that. Because at the end, I was torn about Athelstan. On the one hand, I didn't massively want to promote your book more than you did. It must have been agony for you. But on the other hand, I sort of wanted him to win. Though I do think Elizabeth I, I'm not dissing Elizabeth I. I think she's deservedly a titanic figure in English history in a way that Athelstan actually isn't.
不，好吧，没有重演那一幕挺好的。因为到最后，我对埃塞尔斯坦感到纠结。一方面，我并不是非常想比你更卖力地宣传你的书。这对你来说一定是一种折磨。但另一方面，我某种程度上希望他赢。虽然我认为伊丽莎白一世——我不是在贬低伊丽莎白一世。我认为她当之无愧是英国历史上的巨星，而埃塞尔斯坦实际上并非如此。
No, of course. Yeah. And that's why it's a big story, isn't it? Yeah. Anyway, it's all been great. We need, at some point perhaps, we'll do another historical World Cup. Are we definitely?
不，当然。是的。这就是为什么这是一个大新闻，不是吗？是的。不管怎样，这一切都太棒了。我们需要，也许在某个时候，我们会再办一次历史世界杯。我们一定会吗？
American presidents, perhaps, or Caesars, or the worst kings and queens of England. Yeah. And the worst kings, how would that vote? I mean, would you be voting for the least worst or the genuinely worst? Today we'd have to decide. I mean, obviously, as presidents of this board of sport, that's up to us. Yeah.
也许是美国总统，或者是凯撒大帝，或者是英国最糟糕的国王和女王。是的。最糟糕的国王，投票会怎么样？我是说，你会投给不那么糟糕的还是真正最糟糕的？今天我们得决定。我的意思很明显，作为这项运动董事会的会长，这取决于我们。是的。
But something to look forward to. Definitely. World Cups to come and great podcasts to come. We've got CIA coming up, haven't we? We've got Neanderthals. We've got Napoleon in Egypt. We have the Burgundians. And then we've got Christmas.
但这令人期待。绝对的。未来的世界杯和精彩的播客。我们接下来要讲CIA，对吧？我们有尼安德特人。我们有拿破仑征服埃及。我们有勃艮第人。然后我们要过圣诞节。
We've got Dickens. We've got some more churches. We've got it all. Don't go away. No. See you then. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
我们有狄更斯。我们还有一些教堂。我们应有尽有。不要走开。不。到时候见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。